[Musica]
sono pietre diceva carlo levi dalla
sicilia e sempre in sicilia la alla
cinese la cosiddetta alla cinese della
scuola di palermo del gruppo 63
considerava le parole delle cose ha
delle cose proprio per la loro forma per
il loro colore per il loro suono
composero anche dei testi narrativi
fatti con le parole a prescindere dal
loro significato di verve ero abbastanza
incomprensibili le parole però sono
anche informazioni le informazioni sono
dati sono dati e il nostro mondo sta
cambiando moltissimo
voi vedete che ho una pietra appunto in
mano il nostro mondo sta cambiando
perché si sta aiutando questo è un
brutto neologismo o anglicismo che però
si dice che ci stiamo riempiendo di cose
in grado di interconnettersi alla rete
l'internet delle cose l'internet di
tutte le cose
aiuti internet of things l'internet
delle cose oggi è il presente qualcosa
che tutti conosciamo leggiamo da tanto
tempo però sta per esplodere il 5 g farà
sì che in pochi anni arriveremo a si
dice si prevede 50 miliardi di oggetti
interconnessi e questo che cosa
significa almeno da un punto di vista
giuridico
significa che inevitabilmente ci
trasformeremo in dati in informazioni
anche quando saremo semplicemente
presenti fisicamente materialmente nel
mondo il nostro essere nel mondo fisico
materiale sarà subito anche e sempre di
più un essere dati [ __ ] ti trasformati
in da chi e come se lavorassimo è come
se d'acqua evaporando diventassimo
nuvole
nessuno può più dire ma io non mi
registro io non fornisco i miei dati a
quest'app questo sito a questo servizio
e quindi sono sicuro di non essere
catturato e trasformato in dati no e
vapore remo sempre di più ci saranno
sensori sentinelle a trasformarci in
dati per il nostro essere presenti
fisicamente ce ne saranno sempre di più
alcune sentinelle le vedremo io alcune
le vedo adesso vedo le telecamere vedo
il microfono lo sento addosso a me ma
quante sentinelle potrebbero esserci in
oggetti in tessuti di ogni tipo sulle
poltrone nei cuscini
non pensate al frigorifero che è la cosa
più banale ormai non pensate alla smart
tv pensate a oggetti ancora più piccoli
più insignificanti in grado di catturare
e trasformarci in dati poi in realtà
tutto ciò che è micro tutto ciò che è
nano potrà sposarsi con
l'interconnessione e quindi dobbiamo
abituarci a pensare anche a un
cosiddetto paio di un internet delle
cose delle biotecnologie dei tessuti
umani perché no anche un internet of
blood un internet del sangue delle
cellule noi stessi
saremo potenzialmente pervasi di
sentinelle che si trasformeranno in dati
e questo succederà in maniera abbastanza
inconsapevole e sarà inconsapevole
proprio perché non sarà facile
accorgersi di questi sensori di questi
trasformatori di questi dati fi catori
ora catturata questa miriade di dati che
ci riguardano catturate le nostre
informazioni trasformata la nostra
presenza in dati da
innumerevoli fonti estremamente varie
variabili questi dati verranno vengono
già ma verranno sempre più elaborati
processati velocissimamente con capacità
di elaborazione per volumi straordinari
e il cosiddetto big data
naturalmente il bitetto serve a qualcosa
non solo il big detta ma serve a
elaborare ragionare essere sempre più
intelligenti ma intelligenti chi cosa
gli oggetti comunque algoritmi non umani
immaginate che tutti questi oggetti di
cui vi parlavo poco fa
se la facciano e se la dicano si
scambino informazioni su di noi e come è
normale per ogni big data processing ne
creino di nuove possono nascere nuove
informazioni
altrove in oggetti che stanno lontano e
che noi non sospettiamo nemmeno che
stiano elaborando le nostre informazioni
ci sarà sempre di più qualcuno o
qualcosa ma anche tanti qualcuno o
qualcosa che sapranno molte più cose di
noi di quante noi stessi sappiano e
questa è una forma di subconscio
digitale che arriva a ad avere degli
effetti sulle nostre vite su quello che
noi riceviamo su quello che riceviamo
personalizzato o comunque come targeting
perché siamo obiettivi verso cui
presentare dei contenuti allora io vi ho
detto che volenti o nolenti
inconsapevolmente come non utenti
veniamo trasformati da acqua che siamo e
vapor chiamo e sappiamo e ci ritroviamo
a uno stato gassoso allo stato gassoso
succedono molte cose e ci sono
elaborazioni di dati dati che ci
riguardano creazione di nuovi dati ma
poi viene a piovere magari non piovono
pietre però piove l'acqua torna a
piovere neve viene a nevicare
piove grandina cioè si ritrasforma
quello che per noi è stata semplicemente
una evaporazione una trasformazione del
nostro essere nel mondo fisico in dato
si ritrasforma in qualcosa di materiale
esattamente come un chicco di grandine
che ci arriva in testa e questo come può
accadere accade perché l'internet delle
cose non sarà solo in andata non saranno
semplicemente non sono da oggi sensori
che ci catturano e ci trasformano ma
saranno anche attori agenti attori
oggetti cose che interverranno con
azioni materiali con effetti materiali
che sono derivati che sono conseguenza
di tutto quello che è stato pensato
artificialmente con i nostri dati e con
altri dati ancora lassù tra le nuvole
quindi stiamo attenti non si tratta solo
di un andata si tratta del ritorno
dell'effetto materiale una porta che non
si apre un frigorifero per tornare ad
esempio banale che non si apre o che si
spegne un pacemaker che funziona o non
funziona comunque effetti fisici un
proiettile che parte e che magari è
stato sparato a 10.000 chilometri di
distanza
tutto questo ci deve fare riflettere
perché la protezione dei dati personali
che qualcosa di materiale no il dato che
cos'è la nostra rappresentazione di sé
verso l'esterno verso il mondo esterno
si deve trasformare si sta trasformando
sempre di più in protezione degli
effetti personali in futuro anche questa
disciplina giuridica si trasformerà in
quella direzione
nella carta dei diritti fondamentali
dell'unione europea abbiamo due diversi
articoli 1 e l'articolo 7 che tutela la
sfera privata e la sfera personale degli
individui
l'altro è l'articolo 8 sulla proprio
sulla tutela dei dati personali più
immateriale dobbiamo ripensare quei due
articoli quei due diritti macro diritti
e rifonderli insieme probabilmente
questa è la strada per riuscire a
tutelare veramente gli effetti personali
in un mondo fortemente hai utilizzato e
probabilmente le tutele previste oggi
che sembrano guardare al futuro tutti
voi avrete sentito parlare mille volte
di negli ultimi anni di gdp hardy
regolamento privacy europeo ecco norme
come quelle probabilmente già mostrano
una inadeguatezza un'insufficienza per
questi scenari
pensate solo che il regolamento europeo
il gdp are pensa moltissimo alle
riguarda moltissimo alle tutele
informative cioè all'informativa che
viene data prima di iniziare i
trattamenti di dati ma come ci siamo
detti noi verremo catturati e
trasformati in dati senza accorgercene
gli oggetti non avranno e non hanno
faccia interfaccia non hanno occhi bocca
naso per poter interloquire con noi
darci l'informativa 9 su 10 non
funzionano così
vedete che già anche quel solo istituto
dell'informativa privacy che tra l'altro
pochissimi leggono
fa acqua da tutte le parti e acqua che
potrebbe venire a piovere
e poi c'è un principio nel regolamento
europeo su cui vi voglio fare riflettere
il principio di account ability di
responsabilizzazione
ne hanno parlato tutti i giuristi che si
occupano di queste materie il principio
di responsabilizzazione deve rendere
individuabile account ball
responsabilizzato ciascun soggetto che
decide determinati trattamenti di dati
ma è disegnato per i soggetti esseri
umani è disegnato per rendere account
ball responsabilizzato l'essere umano la
persona o la società l'organizzazione
che ha comunque un consiglio
d'amministrazione fatto di persone ma se
dobbiamo responsabilizzare gli oggetti
gli oggetti non umani come si fa con il
gdp ar con la norma europea attuale non
si fa potrebbero servire tutele
addirittura fisiche per proteggersi nel
futuro hai utilizzato tutele
tridimensionali occhiali per non essere
riconosciuti in forma biometrica dalle
telecamere tecniche di anti radar
portatile personale
ora però vi voglio fare riflettere su un
ulteriore cosa o una pietra in mano ma
immaginate che i dati non siano
semplicemente pietre ciò che ne deriva
non sia semplicemente pioggia neve nella
metafora che facevo prima
ma immaginate che siano anche armi
regole leggi leggi restrittive della
libertà personale per esempio
immaginate che tutto quel mondo di dati
che verranno sempre più catturati e
creati che sarà un mondo di dati al
servizio dell'intelligenza artificiale
non umana
venga utilizzato non semplicemente per
causare effetti nelle piccole cose micro
regole nelle piccole cose della vita
quotidiana che comunque sono
importantissime ma venga utilizzato per
fare qualcosa di più
in tutti i parlamenti in quasi tutto il
mondo per entrare nelle aree legislative
c'è una barriera fisica una barriera
fisica simbolica se andate anche nel
parlamento italiano
c'è una riga alla camera dei deputati
che non può essere superata fisicamente
se non siete gli eletti c'è una tutela
fisica del potere legislativo
ora immaginate che si consenta per
regolamento di un parlamento
un bel giorno la partecipazione da
remoto non parlamentari sono spesso via
chiedono di poter partecipare da remoto
alle sedute di poter iniziare a votare
anche da remoto
chi ci garantisce che in poco tempo quei
voti espressi attraverso quell identità
digitale di un parlamentare o di tanti
parlamentari perfino della maggioranza
non si possano in realtà gestire
attraverso l'intelligenza artificiale
attraverso bot parlamentare i bot
il primo passo potrebbe essere proprio
quello di farli partecipare da remoto i
parlamentari veri il secondo il terzo
tasso potrebbe quello di avere una
maggioranza di parlamentari di voti
espressi per volontà di un algoritmo
sempre più esperto o di più algoritmi
questo è un rischio da scongiurare
dal mio punto di vista è un rischio di
disumanizzazione del potere del potere
legislativo ma naturalmente a tutti i
livelli vale nessuna regola dovrebbe
essere in ultima istanza stabilita da un
algoritmo se non altro perché
l'intelligenza artificiale tende alla
perfezione del cal
l'intelligenza artificiale è una forma e
sarà sempre più una forma di iper
razionalità
se io voglio un calcolo perfetto e devo
raggiungere i miei obiettivi
devo tendere alla iper razionalità ma lì
per razionalità è quanto di meno umano è
quanto di più disumano ci possa essere
il nazismo era iternazionale il
compromesso il perdono l'amore la pace
sono errori di calcolo noi abbiamo
bisogno di questi errori di calcolo
abbiamo bisogno di conservare l'elemento
umano nel legislatore in tutti i livelli
di regolazione il super admin il
comandante in capo
dovrebbe essere sempre un essere umano e
questo vale a maggior ragione per i
parlamenti per questo avrebbe senso
inserire nelle costituzioni di singoli
paesi o anche a livello di trattato
internazionale delle regole nuove
lo stato di diritto per cui nessuno
neppure un re può sentirsi al di sopra
della legge
è una regola importantissima che abbiamo
in democrazia forse è il caso di
aggiornarla perché a quel punto potrebbe
esserci la possibilità per un algoritmo
di decidere la legge allora dovremmo
aggiornare lo stato di diritto la rule
of law e parlare non più di stato di
diritto ma di stato di diritto umano o
di human lo l'ultima parola non dovrebbe
mai essere di pietra non dovrebbe mai
essere di bit dovrebbe essere di carne
ed ossa dovrebbe essere di emozioni e
sentimenti anche di errori umani
grazie
[Applauso]